una fila Aparentemente interminable de
vehículos a primera hora de la mañana
del sábado en París algunos
automovilistas pasaron horas parados con
la esperanza de llenar sus depósitos
me levanté a las 4 de la mañana para ir
a buscar gasolina
tras una larga espera hubo alivio aunque
las existencias eran limitadas
no es la gasolina sino el tiempo que
estoy perdiendo en el coche
la búsqueda de combustible continuó
durante toda la noche la escasez
provocada por las huelgas en las
refinerías ha afectado a una de cada
cinco gasolineras en Francia el norte
del país está especialmente afectado
como en esta estación de servicio de
arras donde se está controlando la
entrada Cuánto tienes tres cuartos no se
puede no no no
solo se permite la entrada a personas
con ocupaciones prioritarias algo que
los automovilistas parecen entender poco
los vehículos prioritarios tienen que
poder repostar y estar disponibles pero
incluso esta trabajadora que pudo llegar
a los surtidores está teniendo
dificultades
la estación que fue reabastecida el
viernes ya no tiene combustible
vine anoche pero no había me dijeron que
los estaban reabasteciendo pero ya no
hay nada voy a probar en el surtidor de
al lado o en el otro o por ahí
el gobierno dice que no hay que entrar
en pánico pero los partidos de la
oposición y aseguran que no está
haciendo lo suficiente para resolver